what do you love more cinematography or
the gear and Tech that brings
cinematography to life W it's such a
great question you know um I've gone
back and forth with that several times
through my life because I started off as
a cameraman as a camera assistant camera
operator and eventually a DP and I
really thought for a long time that that
was what I loved and that was what I was
most interested in
but I also really love the technology
and I got to say that it's some point I
think I discovered that the technology
and what's involved in that is more
perpetually interesting to me uh look
there I I think that all
cinematographers are either well in
order to be a good cinematographer or
the best cinematographer you need to be
part artist and part plumber and if
you're too much artist then and you
don't have the technical chops you're
going to have problems if you're too
much plumber and you're just Technical
and you don't have artistic chops there
will be problems so you really have to
have a good blend of those two things
and I've met hundreds of DPS over the
years and some of them are all artists
and some of them are all plumbers but
definitely I feel like most people lean
towards art uh I have always been
someone who's leaned more towards being
a plumber leaned more towards the
technology and you can do incredible
stuff with the technology if you know
how to optimize every bit of the gear
you're working with and in some ways
it's kind of a cheat you can hack great
cinematography if you understand the the
technical side really really well U but
I'd say for me it's it's probably
leaning more towards
Tech how do you know someone is a camera
and lens nerd are there things that give
it away a little bit and it's always
surprising to me because I feel like
there's some people out there who are
sort of closet camera and lens nerds
that um don't necessarily advertise that
and once you once you start to have a
conversation with someone and they let
little hints sort of slip it's sort of
like you know they they might keep their
their technical status sort of in the
closet they don't really want to like
come immediately forward um when you
start to engage with those DPS when you
start to engage with those people you
can really have a great geek out session
you can really get into you know the
nitty-gritty uh in in my position over
the years uh I've been privy to a lot of
conversations and a lot of the the sort
of stuff that isn't out in the public
when it comes to cameras and lenses and
techn ology and it's really wonderful to
meet someone else who also shares an
interest in all of that because we can
sort of trade stories and I can give
them some insights into technology that
they didn't have before when you deal
with someone who's really only
interested in arts and only interested
in
Aesthetics all of that stuff doesn't
matter to them they they have people for
that there's a person whose job it is to
make sure that the camera works right I
I remember one uh very bigname ASC
cinematographer said to me once who was
definitely all artist and very little
plumber he said
um I just need to know how to drive the
car I don't need to know how the car
works and I thought to myself I guess
that's true I guess if you have a
driver's license you can just drive a
car and you can get from point A to
point B I feel like if you understand
how a car works I I feel like if you
understand the technical aspects of
what's going into it you can get so much
more joy out of that experience espe
especially if you understand horsepower
and shifting and you know how a car
actually gets around corners and what
kind of tires are on the car I feel like
if you are in that mindset of
understanding the relationship between
uh the artist and their tool the artist
and their paintbrush then it's an
entirely different level than I'm only
concerned about sort of the final result
or I'm only concerned about one thing uh
I I wish that people were would take
more interest in the technical side
sometimes I feel like there's a lot of
time that's being spent on YouTube with
people talking about um Aesthetics
without necessarily understanding uh all
the other side of that coin all the
other stuff that goes into it is there a
stigma to being sort of a camera on lens
offici in Auto I mean why would someone
uh not want to uh reveal their status I
think that the reason that people don't
always come right out with that is
because uh you start to talk another
language and I know I have to be very
ious of this too especially like
um it's not great at parties when you're
with a couple of other you know
technical people and you start talking
shop and you're talking to this because
it you immediately start to alienate
other people from the conversation and
they're I'm not going to say it's quite
a club but there is essentially an a
Very free flowing Association of people
who are very technical who work at the
highest levels in the industry and they
all know each other and we can bounce
questions off each other because there
aren't a lot of people who you can
actually have those conversations with
there's only a few other people out
there who really under understand at the
highest level and to all know each other
and be able to have those conversations
is really wonderful once you uh have to
tone the conversation to you know aay
environment it becomes a bit more
simplistic and it becomes a bit more
vague and there's a lot of people on the
YouTubes and whatnot out there who try
to share information and try to say that
they're technical or maybe they're just
reading off specs from manufacturers but
that doesn't actually get into really
what's happening because ultimately what
we're talking about with cinematography
is we're talking about photons we're
talking about light we're talking about
the artistic process of light that is
being emitted that's being bent by
lenses and that's being captured by
image sensors which is converting
photons into electrons and that that
means we're talking about you know the
quantum realm it means we're talking
about massless forms of energy that
essentially is blasting you know quite
the number one light source you see is
93 million miles away this is really you
know I think fascinating stuff and
really geeky stuff that people can get
into because you know actually those
photons are bouncing off of bouncing off
of materials all around us all in this
room and depending on what the light
source is and what it's reflecting off
to off of it's actually forcing
electrons to move out of their orbit and
there's all kinds of just you know I
think really interesting stuff about
this when we start to talk about color
and I know I feel like I'm already going
off the deep end here for your audience
but for the most part um there is
something really beautiful in science
and what we're doing here in
cinematography is trying to do something
very aesthetic and something very
beautiful scientifically at least I I I
think so how did you discover what your
strengths and weaknesses are within
cinematography yeah uh it's interesting
because
um I really wasn't sure what my
strengths and weaknesses were in the
early days is I went to film school and
I think like a lot of other students
there I didn't know anything I didn't
realize what I didn't know it wasn't
until I started getting out into the
real world and I started working which I
I was fortunate enough to start getting
some basic production assistant and
Camera assistant jobs while I was still
in school but it was amazing to learn a
craft from people who were very
experienced who'd been doing it a lot
longer than I have been and to have them
start imparting uh the me methodology
into me of the craft so uh I learned
right away that uh I sometimes spoke way
too much I had opinions about things
that when you're a crafts person you're
not necessarily supposed to have
opinions about and uh I also learned
that I knew from a young age I was very
mechanically inclined so I did gravitate
towards technology it's it's a little
bit like um starting off as a production
assistant working on a set it's a little
bit like a a living aptitude test you
get an understanding right away if
you're um introverted or extroverted and
who your people are who are you most
like who are who's your tribe there's
various tribes that all kind of get
along and work together and if you've
got a big
personality probably a good chance you
might be like uh in the ad Department an
assistant director if you are more
technically minded you might end up in
camera or you might end up in one of the
other crafts and I sort of found my
found my people early on and discovered
that this is what I'm
into